die entscheidende woche über krieg oder
frieden in europa sie hat begonnen die
vielleicht letzte chance für eine
diplomatische lösung der ukraine krise
es gibt zahlreiche neue entwicklungen in
den vergangenen 24 stunden und die
wichtigste ist nach gesprächen mit
frankreichs präsidenten haben sich
russlands präsident putin und
us-präsident beiden grundsätzlich zu
einem zweier gipfel bereit erklärt die
außenminister der beiden länder sollen
das an diesem donnerstag noch
vorbereiten gleichzeitig nehme aber auch
die spannungen zu putin hat heute morgen
und noch für heute den nationalen
sicherheitsrat zu einer
ausserordentlichen sitzung einberufen
die lage in der ost ukraine ist also
extrem angespannt es gibt beschuss und
provokation und genau dort an der front
ist unser reporter paul ronzheimer paul
du hast diesen beschuss auch selbst
erlebt vielleicht mag es noch mal
beschreiben
ja das ist die situation die hier jeder
minute passieren kann ich bin gerade in
einer stellung der ukrainischen armee
weil es um uns herum wieder
mörserbeschuss gegeben hat gerade vor
einer viertelstunde das ist eine
situation mit der zivilisten hier leben
müssen kinder frauen eben nicht nur
soldaten sondern ganz ganz viele
menschen die nichts mit diesen krieg zu
tun haben und das ist das eigentlich
dramatische sie alle hoffen jetzt dass
es tatsächlich möglichkeiten der
entspannung gibt allerdings hören wir
von russischer seite dass dmitri peskow
der sprecher von wladimir putin diesen
optimismus schon wieder gebremst hat und
gesagt hat ich sei noch nicht ganz klar
ob es zu diesem summit ob es zu diesem
treffen kommen wir zwischen putin und
beiden und gleichzeitig hören wir aus
unseren quellen das ist jetzt russische
vorwürfe gibt die ukraine habe einen
grenzposten innerhalb russlands
beschossen bei roscoff das ist das was
momentan hier
schwirrt sozusagen in der ukraine und
das ist ja auch das was putin will alles
er will einen text schaffen ein grund
möglicherweise schaffen um ihr seine
truppen in die ukraine zu bringen und
das ist das wovor die ukraine auch hier
diesen stellung angst haben umso mehr
gilt es jetzt die nerven zu bewahren
vielen dank paul ronzheimer deutschlands
außenministerin annalena baerbock hat
heute eben noch mal an putin appellierte
spielen sie nicht mit menschenleben hat
sie gesagt dass der menschen im dombasle
hoch gefährdet auch in kiew sind wir vor
ort mit unserem reporter peter hell und
er hat einen gottesdienst dort besucht
die frage ist hilft jetzt womöglich nur
noch beten
ich denke nicht über die angst nach ich
hoffe nur dass wir in frieden leben
können denn wir sind nur menschen wir
bitten gott darum uns stärke zu geben
damit wir glücklich und in frieden leben
können
ich weiß nicht was passieren wird alles
was wir tun können ist an gott zu
glauben vorbereitet zu sein und zusammen
zu halten denn nur zusammen können wir
uns und unser land verteidigen niemand
weiß ob wir angegriffen werden aber wir
müssen vorbereitet sein
wenn meine familie und meine heimat
attackiert werden würde ich kämpfen
ja ich habe angst aber ich bin sicher
dass unsere armee stark ist
ich weiß nicht ob putin angreifen wird
ich denke schon aber weiß nicht wann
vielleicht nicht heute oder morgen
sind sie bereit zu kämpfen ja ich habe
keine angst ich bin bereit zu kämpfen
und wir schalten jetzt live nach kiew zu
unserem reporter peter helga peter wie
würdest du die lage derzeit dort
beschreiben wie viel angst haben die
menschen
die lage ist natürlich völlig
unterschiedlich zu paul an der front
hier ist die stadt hier sind drei
millionen 27 millionen menschen man
merkt kaum etwas von diesen krieg
zuständen die sich im osten abspielen
aber hier auf dem majdan
wo wir gerade stehen hier da merkt man
schon dass die leute so ein bisschen
hektischer geworden sind wir uns auch
gestern in der kirche gesehen also es
ist immer so eine eine eine stimmung
zwischen angst hoffnung und mittlerweile
auch wut dass man endlich mal jetzt
möchte dass sich das entscheidet denn
diese schreckliche situation dieser
ungewissheit eventuell auch hier in kiew
angegriffen zu werden
die zieht sich natürlich jetzt schon
über monate hin und wir haben es ja von
den gläubigen gehört von den
kirchenbesuchern es ist eine mischung
aus wut trauer aber eben auch aus
entschlossenheit und wenn man hier am
tag ist geht man hier durch die straßen
es ist eigentlich ein ganz normales
leben aber im hintergrund merkt man
schon man bereitet sich eigentlich auf
das schlimmste vor man hofft natürlich
dass es jetzt zu einem treffen kommen
könnte zwischen präsident biden und
putin dass man eventuell noch weiter
verhandelt und dass die kriegshandlungen
aufhören wird er sollte es zu einem
angriff auch auf tiere tatsächlich
kommen wie können sich die menschen dann
dort überhaupt schützen
na ja man ist hier eigentlich ganz gut
vorbereitet ich stehe jetzt hier zum
beispiel an der u-bahn an dem meiler
könnte man runter gehen das ist einer
von 250 u bahnstationen eingänge und
diese u bahn ist die zweitgrößte der
welt die geht nämlich 100 meter in die
tiefe eine station weiter ist die
tiefste oberligist 105 meter und man hat
hier in kiew etwa gesorgt für etwa 5000
schutzräume das heißt alle menschen 2,7
millionen menschen hätten theoretisch
schutz das wird jetzt auch in übung
dargestellt und die leute bereiten sich
auch vor und man sagt natürlich falls es
dazu kommen sollte dass sogar
luftangriffe stattfinden oder dass die
russen hier einmarschieren dass die
menschen dann eben wirklich wenn es hart
auf hart kommt hier unten in diesen
räumlichkeiten in diesen
u-bahn-stationen schutzfilm könnten nur
ob das letzten endes auch eine lösung
ist es ist natürlich erstmal sicherheit
geht vor die leben müssen gerettet
werden aber so richtig glücklich ist da
keiner mit aber die regierung
beziehungsweise auch hier der
bürgermeister vitali klitschko die
sorgen natürlich in dieser größten stadt
dafür dass die menschen wenn es so weit
sein sollte dass sie daneben sicher vor
eventuellen bombe schuss sein können
vielen dank hinterher live aus kers
dankeschön für diese eindruck ja und wir
konnten heute morgen auch mit dem
bürgermeister von kiew mit vitali
klitschko persönlich sprechen dabei hat
er betont dass die ukraine bereit sind
für ihr land zu kämpfen und waffen
unterstützung und nicht nur herrn aus
deutschland vor
hoffen wir hoffen wir auf die
dramatische werk dass dieser konflikt
wird
lösen aber wenn nein dann leider keine
andere wahl wir müssen unsere landungen
der familie italien heute hat die
deutsche verteidigungsministerium gesagt
dass die 5000 helme die deutschland der
ukraine schicken will versand bereit
sind die könnten in drei tagen da sein
sie waren schon mal sehr wütend über
dieses angebot wahrscheinlich auch jetzt
für sie keine beruhigende nachricht
ich bin nicht wütend da wo das es
klingt das wäre ein witz wir brauchen
eine verteidigungswaffen das ist eine
der großen mächtigste armee steht da
auch von unserer grenze aus und mit
den visionen durch reine ich möchte ich
weiß die durchs land eine großbeeren der
unterstützung die hochreine hat immer
und das gelebte geld investiert in
unsere wirtschaft formal zu machen in
unserem land wie der staat zu machen
aber jetzt in diese situation helme ich
möchte noch einmal bedanken dass es
hilft diese aber zu verteidigen und zu
verteidigen gegen adresse die helme das
einfach nie genug
einfach nicht genug bei uns im studio
ist der künftige fdp generalsekretär
bijan djir sarai
herr beginn des 3 vitali klitschko sagt
das ist nicht genug würden sie sagen
dass es für alle zeiten ausgeschlossen
sind dass auch deutsche waffen geliefert
werden wenn es tatsächlich zu
kriegerischen handlungen in der ukraine
kommen ich habe in der vergangenheit
schon gesagt dass gerade in zusammenhang
mit diesem thema alle optionen auf dem
tisch sein müssen bleiben müssen also
aufwachen
schauen sie mal herr putin teilt uns
auch nicht mit was seine nächsten
schritte sind und was seine strategie
ist warum sollen wir im vorfeld immer
alles mitteilen und transparent bei dem
thema seien deswegen er kategorisch nein
aber es wäre doch äußerst unklug ob
jetzt mit bei militärischen fragen aber
auch bei wirtschaftspolitik oder
finanzpolitische fragen es wäre äußerst
unklug wenn wir von vornherein welche
option einfach ausschließen würden oder
diese vom tisch nehmen die herzige seien
ausgeschlossen stellte dabei die
richtigen fragen beispielsweise oder sie
haben ja mich jetzt eingeladen und ich
bin nicht herr stegner reader writer
kommission hat ich bin der designierte
generalsekretär der fdp auch nicht der
regierungssprecher aber nichtsdestotrotz
ich halte nach wie vor es für sinnvoll
dass alle optionen auf dem tisch bleiben
es muss nach wie vor ganz klar gegenüber
moskau vor allem gegenüber herrn putin
signalisiert werden dass sollte es zu
einer eskalation kommt der preis dafür
außerordentlich hoch sein wird für
russland ausbauen also keine
einheitliche linie innerhalb der
ampelkoalition was heißt hier
einheitliche linie ich glaube dass
sowohl der bundeskanzler als auch die
bundesaußenministerium ja auch bei jeder
gelegenheit betonen dass alle optionen
auf dem tisch sein müssen das ist ja
nicht irgendein spruch sondern dass es
tatsächlich auch eine konkrete strategie
können sie verstehen dass das wir holen
und sport auch verein bei vitali
klitschko sorgt dass ihr 5000 handy
schicken wollen ich kann das ich kann
das nachvollziehen wir
werden ja auch übrigens dieser konflikt
wird ja komplett die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
verändern und wir werden ja auch künftig
mehr geld für sicherheitspolitik
ausgeben müssen und mit blick auf die
ukraine gehe ich fest davon aus dass wir
auch dort mehr im militärischen bereich
machen müssen jetzt nicht im sinne von
waffenlieferungen um ihr falsch
verstanden zu werden sondern auch wir
werden künftig mehr tun müssen wenn es
beispielsweise um die ausbildung und
verbesserung der rheinische gerade heute
ausgeschlossen wir werden das sehen ich
glaube dass es nach auf dauer eine
komponente ist eine debatte ist mit
zukunft ich glaube es ist sinnvoll
beispielsweise offiziere aus der ukraine
in deutschland auszubilden dass es ein
beitrag was weiterhin erfolgen also was
künftig erfolgen kann und aus meiner
sicht ist es außerordentlich wichtig
dass wir vor allem wirtschaftlich und
finanziell die ukraine unterstützen der
westen droht er mit
wirtschaftssanktionen sollte es zu
dieser invasion kommen ist es dann aber
nicht viel zu spät ich meine es geht ja
jetzt momentan um leben und tod jetzt
wird ja alles dafür getan dass eine
diplomatische lösung erreicht wird das
dauert selbstverständlich diplomatie
dauert immer und es gibt nur es gibt
keine alternative zu einer
diplomatischen lösung
man muss alles dafür tun damit hier
dieser konflikt beendet wird das wird
übrigens nicht gelingen denn selbst wenn
es nicht zur militärischen maßnahmen
kommt russland wird dauerhaft versuchen
die ukraine zu destabilisieren übrigens
wird auch russland alles dafür tun um
neben den nächsten jahren europa zu
stabilisieren da müssen wir uns darüber
im klaren sein trotzdem hat ihr
außenpolitischer experte graf lambsdorff
heute gesagt man müsse auch der nato man
müsste die auch die nato müsse russland
etwas anbieten also sicherheitsgarantien
offenbar sind das verständliche wünsche
aus sicht von graf lambsdorff dann
schauen sie diese diese debatte um die
so genannte sicherheitsgarantien das ist
keine realistische debatte das was
russland sagt ist nicht realistisch
wovor hat denn russland anfangs hatte
etwa russland angst ernst auf angst vor
der ukraine hat russland angst vor polen
oder vor deutschland oder vor schweden
diese sicherheitsgarantien es ist ja es
ist ja die ukraine die von russland
machen verrät und nicht nur umgekehrt
putin will auf dauer putins ag da ist in
erster linie in politischer natur und
nicht außenpolitischer natur putin will
verhindern dass vor der haustür
russlands demokratische europäische und
wirtschaftlich erfolgreiche strukturen
entstehen das ist der grund warum putin
die ukraine de stabilisiert übrigens
dass es auch der grund warum putin
seinen beitrag geleistet hat damit in
belarus die opposition damit
demokratische strukturen keine chance
haben dass putins größte angst ist dass
eines tages die menschen in seinem
eigenen land aufstehen und sagen wir
wollen reformen wir wollen veränderungen
und wir wollen demokratie das ist seine
größte sorge ganz herzlichen dank für
das gespräch im studio